من السياسة يا عزيزي فقد
اتعبتنا. هلا اجبت من فضلك. ما
كنت اريد آآ هاي ما بك؟ لم اعهدك
مترددا هكذا. قل ولا تخف ولا
واخبرني عن اسعار النفط لديكم
هذه الايام. انسحاب تكتيكي يا
لي لماذا تم اخراج الحرس من
قائمة الارهاب. هذه معلومة
القيادة الامريكية باستحالة
القضاء على هذه المؤسسة من خلال
هكذا. اه. حسنا. اذا من الذي قتل
قاسم سليماني احد اقوى قادة
لهذا السلاح. واذا جاء اليوم
الذي تندلع الحرب فيه فالسلاح
وما الذي ستفعله لتنقذ اليابان
ان قرر مجنون كوريا الشمالية
امريكا يا صديقي. بغارة جوية
مطلع الفين وعشرين في بغداد
لكن ملف ايران تختص به الولايات
المتحدة الامريكية وليس اسرائيل.
فربما ارادت ان تتجنب الحرب
المباشرة مع اسرائيل بهذه الخطوة
من فالدول المصنعة للسلاح كثيرة
وليست اسرائيل فقط هي من تستطيع
انها تمحو اسرائيل من الخارطة
وخلال نصف ساعة فقط. لا يا عزيزي
العلاج الطبي للثوار السوريين.
ام تفكر كما افكر؟ اتقصد انها
ان ايران كانت تستورد السلاح من
اسرائيل ولولا التوترات الحاصلة
فاسرائيل لديها جيش من اقوى
الجيوش وسلاح مدمر في المقابل
ايران تمضي في برنامجها النووي
رغم الضغوطات التي تحدثت عنها.
حرب بالوكالة في المنطقة؟ لا
يبدو لذلك منطقيا. ما الذي جعل
لشيء معين فما هو يا صديقي? مم
آآ الحقيقة فهو لقد آآ قلت لك
تدرس هذا القرار فعلا. اتدري
لماذا? نعم يا صديقي. فواشنطن
الكراهية والفتنة الطائفية. لقد
قلت لك من البداية. دعنا من
شعبا مسلما باكمله. فهم يصلون
كما تصلي ويصومون كما تصوم. ولا
ايران فانها تعمل على الملف
النووي منذ سنوات طويلة ولا احد
والمسلمين? ماذا تقول يا رجل اذا
غرتك السياسة القيادة فلا تظلم
مهلا توقف لوهلة. هل يكون الفرس
هم من يدافعون عن الاسلام
هذه الدول التي ذكرتها مع ايران
لكن هذا الشيء ليس كالشيء الذي
تدرس شطب الحرس الثوري من قائمة
المنظمات الارهابية. بسبب قناعة
الجانب النووي يعتقد ان تل تمتلك
اقل من خمسمائة رأس نووية. اما
نووية تستطيع نحو اسرائيل من
الكرة الارضية في اقل من ساعة.
لا زلت تتابع وضع العالم اليوم.
دعني وشأني. فما عدت اطيق متابعة
بين البلدين لاستمرت ايران بذلك
الاستيراد. ولماذا قد تستورد
ليس الامر كما تتخيله انت. اي رد
هذا الذي سيكون قاسيا. الم تعلم
شكلت اسرائيل في عام الفين وواحد
وعشرين تحالفا امنيا في الخليج
تحجيم قدرات ايران العسكرية فهي
دولة نووية رغم كل الضغوطات
الاحداث العالمية وما عدت اطيق
حتى نفسي. لكن يبدو انك اتصلت بي
واللبنانية ضد عدوهم الاسرائيلي.
وبالتالي فالمستفيد الاول من
اسرائيل سيكون كتابا مفتوحا
الايرانيين بانك في قاعة
الصين بقوتها العظيمة? الا ترى
ايضا الحليف المجنون كيم جونغ
القول بان روسيا هي اقوى واول
حلفاء ايران ام تريد ان اذكر لك
اخر. وقل لي من سيقف بجانب ايران
ان قامت الحرب? حسنا هل يكفي
دمت تريد ذلك فاسمع. اسرائيل
تهدف الى منع ايران من انتاج
خاطئة. فامريكا لم تشطب الحرس
الثوري من قائمة الارهاب ولكنها
ايران عشرة اضعاف عدد سكان
اسرائيل بينما يبلغ عدد جنود
تصدق الاعلام يا صديقي. فالاعلام
يدس السم في العسل ليأسر عقول
صديقي. ودعك من اسعار النفط.
فالوضع لدينا يرثى له. لكن يبدو
السياسة. وانت تصر الا ان تصدع
رؤوسنا بها. دعنا منها يا
لبنان وسوريا ضد عدوهم
الاسرائيلي. الا يعد هذا تدخلا
تفعل امريكا بوقوفها مع الدولة
التي تبدأ بالعدوان على غيرها.
الشيء ذاته? واين رأيت ذلك?
ايران تدعم حركة حماس والمقاومة
تكون اقوى دولة في العالم لكن
الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية كشفت
يربط امريكا باسرائيل فايران تقف
مع المظلومين لاخذ حقوقهم لا كما
ايران يا صديقي؟ هذا طبعا ما
تعتقده اسرائيل. امريكا ربما
الفين وواحد. لماذا تحشر
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
غزوها، وما الذي ستفعله ان قررت
الصين اجتياح تايوان. ان ترى
الكثير. اخبرني ما الذي عملته
امريكا لتنقذ حليفتها الاوكرانية
الاختبار ومعك كتاب المادة التي
ستختبر فيها. اها. فانت تفكر
الجيش الايراني اكثر من ثلاثة
اضعاف الجيش الاسرائيلي وحتى في
انها تطلق تهديدات ووعودا دون
بها? لا تجب على السؤال بسؤال
تمتلك اسرائيل دعما غربيا كبيرا
جدا ياتي في مقدمة حلفائها.
الشعوب ويعكس نظرة الناس تجاه
الشعوب الاخرى ويزرع بذرة
ذلك. الا تعلم ان امريكا هي اقوى
واول حليف لاسرائيل؟ نعم هي كذلك
واعترفت امريكا بذلك ولم تنكر
العملية وليس لاسرائيل يدا في
الفلسطينية ضد اسرائيل? وهذا جلي
للعيان? كما ان طهران تقف مع
هجوم عسكري. على غرار مهاجمة
حركة طالبان في افغانستان. عام
في شؤون الغير? اذا ايران ذلك
فبداع الدين الاسلامي الذي يشمل
ايران العسكريين. والذي كان يجوب
دول المنطقة لدعم حلفائها. قتلته
اون زعيم كوريا الشمالية? هذا
يكفي انت تهرف بما لا تعرف? قل
انفها في جميع القضايا
الاسرائيلي? هو ليست ايران تفعل
امريكا والاتحاد الاوروبي ودول
الخليج العربي فما الذي تمتلكه
يعلم ما الذي تمتلكه. لذلك
فاسرائيل لن تغامر بحرب دولية
مقتله هي اسرائيل وليست ويبدو ان
امريكا قتلته بايعاز من تل ابيب.
الذي يجعلك متأكدا الى هذه
الدرجة. اولا يبلغ عدد سكان
الحرس الثوري الايراني وهو من
يقوم بدعم المقاومة الفلسطينية
لمواجهة ايران. اعلمت بذلك? نعم
ولكن الرد كان قاسيا من ايران
الا تعلم ان قاسم سليماني هو
قائد فيلق القدس اقوى فرقة في
او قد تخطط لاكتشاف اسرار السلاح
الاسرائيلي لتتمكن من صنع مضادات
احدى الدول التي تمارس ضغطا
دوليا على طهران? لكن يا صديقي
اسرائيل لن تحبذ مواجهة ايران
ابدا ولن تقوم بخطوة كهذه. ما
ذلك. هلا وضحت لي هذا اكثر? حسنا
يا صديقي. ايران دولة ذكية.
ايران سلاحا اسرائيليا وهي قادرة
على تصنيع الاسلحة وان كان ولابد
تخجل. فانا عدت اهتم لشيء في هذا
العالم. هيا قل. ما الذي تريده؟
اخرج ما في قلبك قل لي ما الذي
يجول في خاطرك؟ حسنا. صراحة لن
الغربية. قلت بنفسك. الضغوطات
الغربية. هل تعلم ان اسرائيل هي
يتفوق عليه قليلا. لكن هناك بعض
العقوبات الامريكية التي تحاول
مرحبا يا صديقي. مرحبا. هذا انت
ما الذي تريده مجددا? انا لا
اريد شيئا. فقط اتصلت بك لاطمئن
على حالك. واردت ان ارى اذا كنت
تفكر هكذا. لدى كل طرف القدرة
على شن الهجمات على الطرف الاخر.
تمتلك ايران اسلحة نوعية وجيشا
يضاهي الجيش الاسرائيلي او قد
ارتاح قبل ان اسألك. برأيك هل
تستطيع اسرائيل ضرب ايران؟ دعنا
قوات ايرانية في سوريا لدعم
حكومة دمشق اما اسرائيل فتقدم
اسلحة نووية واضعاف حلفائها
واتباعها في المنطقة بينما تحارب
ان الايام القادمة حبلى
بالمفاجأة السارة.